das ist ein geländetaugliches gefängnis
muss der skill endete für ausgelegt ein
geländetaugliches er hat mindestens 30
ps und werde ich viel bodenfreiheit und
herzlich willkommen zur zweiten folge
gta online heißt nachdem wir in der
letzten folge das flugzeug geklaut haben
geht es heute weiter mit dem basf ich
bin etwas mit dabei haben wir heute
wieder jetzt mal den wollte was geht so
friese und thomas geht die handlung
hässlich maske
diese maske weiter wir müssen unbedingt
unbedingt anderer massen ziel
absperrband ihr könnt eure massen stehe
selbst auswählen und natürlich noch
gianluca der 2007 als rallye bei euch
seid einsatzbereit
sehr schön wars noch mal rein
pink ist am besten alles da ich im
vierteiler geholt ich habe extra
viertürer dabei auch okay genug aber
auch jede lassen dass mich dann lasst
mich den links fahren in kuba
nein
ok alles da jetzt und der stirbt erst
mal jeweils von einer weiterhin lokal wo
geht's hin
ok alles 3,3 die beine kommt die untere
teile meines computers sieht gerade vor
dem gameplay leute toyo ito die sterne
gesehen ok gas geben das ging das alles
echt richtig laut schleck musste ich
gleich noch mal runter pegeln im
teamspeak euro ganze scheiße sind die
bullen schon wieder egal muss man es
nicht stell dich doch nicht quer du oh
mein gott
oder braucht die sterne was meinst du ja
ok wahrscheinlich schon
das macht sie sich einfach weil wir
schon mit stern.de driften dann habe ich
mir von den anderen audi rein okay hier
ist ja wo ist alles klar
wir müssen weiter
wie soll jetzt einen gefangenen bus
clown leute denn wir wissen müssen wir
den raschkowski aus dem gefängnis und
das war knapp
dafür brauchen wir ein flugzeug um den
ausser landes zu fliegen
davor aber mein gefängnis muss um ihn
aus dem gefängnis heraus spuren zu
können die unis gefängnis reinkommt zu
kommen glaube ich ja wir verbrauchen
gefängnis bus und ich musste mich noch
die straße konzentrieren
sorry for party warum sind die der links
aggro du bist nicht mein richtiger bulle
als partner töchter spielt sich darauf
weiter gibt es ja nicht fall sogar das
aus der parkplatzwächter alle bewaffnet
amerika wenn du amerika die polizisten
beleidigt dann zieht zuerst mal die ecke
von ist uns auch die reifen wir bald den
weg frei
die bullen nerven aber echt sondern die
feuer loswerden wenn wenn ja wenn er
geht ich sage ganz versperrt
er kommt nein wenn es sich ergibt dass
sie wohl uns nicht mehr jagen wollen
dann sei es so fahren mit anderen
spielern plus 200 rpgs womit sich die
ganze dass man raus leute gesät und es
nicht mehr ansieht
er muss übrigens gleich den besten käse
ist besser als eine stätte für sein
alter ab geht das in hildesheim sind
dies in der luft über dem bus wird weil
der von dem heli bewacht er ist glaube
ich zumindest ich weiß sommer den ids
runterholen
ich glaube ich vermute der bus fährt
jetzt hier auf die autobahn auf ja genau
das statt 19 ok zugedacht stahl hätte
würde ich trotzdem vor also definitiv
mit anleitung der feld andersrum vor
herunter holen wir können sie auch so
machen dass das 24 einsteigen und dann
genau gehört zwar im bus eine steigerung
von uns und die anderen zwei machen
irgendwie die restliche geschichte ok
hier ist okay wir fahren als vor dem bus
und sobald ihr vor dem bus sind alle
nach hinten öffnen wir das voll auf den
fahrer und ich hab ich habe ihn als
fahrer star ok sehr gut sehr gut sehr
gut das ist scheiße aussieht okay nein
da achten jetzt rein
ok ich fahre mit wenn ich jetzt am
steuer
ok also jetzt müssen die wollust werden
könnt ihr das machen die jungs sind mit
einem chor öfter
sechseinhalb stunden später wie die
übertreiber den straßensperren ein
rollerfahrer erwischt was stimme vor der
bus explodiert alte schwede
ja ich glaube die wollen uns ne wisst
ihr was wir machen die ganze spanne tour
einfach hier
das ist ein geländetaugliches gefängnis
muss dafür ausgelegt ein
geländetaugliches die hat mindestens 30
ps und redefreiheit und da musste selbst
bewusster drin egal aber hier oben ist
gut und schön
na wie sieht's bei euch aus der brust
wahrscheinlich das auch wiederholen
wir können wir können nicht in den
bergen gab mir das sehr unfair denn von
den polizisten gegenüber eine gewisse
fairness bewahren ok wenn wir sind die
sterne los und weiter wir müssen noch
abschütteln
der bursche steckengebliebene ich komme
mir vor wie es hier nicht raus man
munkelt ja dass wir solche wusste
manchmal stecken bleiben die bullen
verwundert die straße ist eigentlich
okay fragt einfach ins gebirge rein das
funktioniert immer sehr gut
die blinken jetzt schon investiert aus
erstklassig derweil nicht erwischen
wir gucken mal hier drüben so lange ich
weiß was tom beck aber ein bisschen das
camp an was sie so machen dürfen keine
sterne kassieren alles klar dass ganz
friedfertig
es geht doch nicht wir gucken uns hier
so nicht mehr als wissen um ich glaube
wir sind wir unter uns ich glaube die
leute hier die erwarten die ankunft der
aliens was steht hier safe universe
lifesaver also die erwarten über die
aliens hier und wir laufen mit
absperrband durch die gegen alles klar
passen ich fahre ja alles klar
liebe freunde wir müssen wieder
aufbrechen dürfen wir die jetzt in
headshot geben bitte den hedgehog geben
wir stellen ja selbst können wir sterne
aber okay ich halte mir sind jetzt
verlängern
was jetzt popkultur referenzen ist okay
es ist in dem bus nur noch weg bringen
ok wegbringen hinbringen seine cross
country fahren ist immer bisschen
auskennt weiß was wir können einfach ab
hier
wir kürzen einfach ein bisschen ab okay
da vorne schon bald wieder zurück
gebracht ist
du bist schon weitergefahren was wie
eine 4 5 mal zurückbekam außerdem ein
bisschen körnig das geht ja okay das
schon so toll alles ist die luft rein zu
fahren
alles rein alles war okay das reicht
noch super plus
der du bist du zufrieden und sagen gut
gemacht und jetzt habe ich hab' ich
platinplatten platin silber
es ist ja das gleiche was ist einfach
genau die gleiche aufstellung wie beim
letzten mal
ja es macht keinen sinn ich habe gar
nichts beschlossen
übrigens für den schwarzwald allerdings
nur in der sequenz war nur ganz kurze
okay leute wie immer lasten downloads
gefallen hat wie es bei der nächsten
folge wieder und checkt auf die anderen